okay so today we're going to talk about
blockchain technology and give you a
high-level overview of what it is and
how it work blockchain it emerged in
2008 out of cryptocurrency specifically
Bitcoin that we have white paper
published and that's really where it all
started so we start I guess by defining
what it is blockchain technology is a
distributed decentralized system in
which all parties have a entire record
and can view the transactions that took
place
decentralized and distributed network
and can throw that out to explain what a
decentralized distribution network
actually is so in a classic centralized
network you have a central node to which
all other nodes in the network connect
this in a distributed system you might
have clusters of those with a few links
between them something a bit like this
but if you know this node is knocked
offline you lose the part of the data
that was stored on that kisum in a
distributed systems like a peer-to-peer
network you have something a bit more
like this here you can think of talking
a bit back in database terms your
database is sharded and distributed in
components part across your network in
this distributed decentralized solution
all parties have a complete record of
the database and system combined
together to act as one single database
with each individual node having a
complete copy of all of all transactions
and micaceous blockchain so here you've
got centralized
here you've got a decentralized network
where you've got clusters with only a
few nodes connecting the individual
clusters and here in this moral lattice
pattern you've got a distributed and
decentralized network you can think of
the blockchain system as a distributed
ledger or internal tracking database
time a transaction based based place
that's what it fundamentally
it stores a ledger of transactions and
it's also immutable which is say it
can't it can be updated you new sets of
transactions can be added to it but it
can't be on one come things added that
block cannot and should not be changed
or mutated any further the core
technologies that underpin blockchain is
hash codes hash puzzles Merkle trees and
public private key cryptography in the
sort of common parlance of Bitcoin you
have it was only a Bitcoin wallet that's
actually your public key in your private
public key cryptography I know they can
earlier cookies file on private key
encryption but essentially in the case
you of blockchain
you have your your wallet your your
public key and your private key and an
interesting thing about at least the way
Bitcoin is implemented on the blockchain
technology it's all or nothing so the
total wealth of my current wallet has to
be spent in a transaction so if I've got
5 bitcoins using the Bitcoin in
technology and only one he can one to
you then I can one coin to you and four
back to myself but I had to do initially
cut Kyoto transaction I basically say
that that one we cannot efficient to you
I don't necessarily know you I don't
know who you are there's no reason for
us to have met or me to even know your
name what I'm really saying is the
wallet that is labeled by this public
key the person who owns the
corresponding private key to that public
key I'm authorizing them to take
ownership of this one bit going and
that's how public private key encryption
is using it is you means of legitimizing
menteur authoring transy actually said
yes I have said you can spend this
amount
I wish transferred the amount to you and
you know that that turns got originated
from me and somebody else on the network
poking at me
the other thing is
depression hash codes and Merkle trees
basically I can please throw this out
another interesting thing about the way
how she's work is for a given input if I
have an a B key my input and I put that
through hashing algorithms and I get the
output on my hero's 5bg I only have to
change this margin link a I add a B C
and I add B to it and it will completely
change the corresponding code you only
have to change the input in a small way
to get a drastically different expert
coming out that will be of the same
uniform length a preceding one despite
the fact the input which of a different
length you can think of it is like
labeling it with a I'm going to use
unique carefully here key there are in
occasions you do hash collisions where
different input resolves to the same
hash but you're aiming toward uniqueness
and the idea is you can think of it as
like a fixed-length signature for a
given input so how this feature further
in in blockchain is a blockchain
technology the transactions we talked
about earlier are grouped to get you
know you can think of transactions when
they first published to the network if
you're kicking out there in the ether
and then the job you might have heard of
sort of miners in blockchain technology
the job of a miner is to gather a bunch
of these two transactions together form
them into a block and the project of
doing that is what involves hashing and
the process of checking that a block
remains immutable and hasn't been
changed it goes on to market areas which
I'll draw in the next diagram but
essentially one key I've formed my block
my block has a corresponding hash code
and how Merkle trees come into it if we
start with basic blocks of content that
we want to represent in our tree
structure in generating our next know
gr3 I'm just going to use H to represent
hash function of a and B and the value
of that comes to label this node in our
tree
likewise over here take the hash of B C
key and then here at our top level we
take the hash of the hash of a and B and
the hash of C and key and that
represents our next level up in the tree
and the interesting thing about this
structure and about hash code is we
remember from this diagram you only have
to change your input a tiny bit to
change the output so if I change this
base content I make it locates rather
than upper case for example this will
then change to this as puzzle become
valid as wick and it will press rate and
filter back up and that is the core of
blockchain technology in terms of how
plots are stored and how it's in it in a
city in a distributed system when no one
knows anybody else how you know and can
be certain that the transaction cannot
been tampered with
because everyone can see this chain of
blocks having talked about some the
underlying data structures give an
example of how transactions are grouped
into blocks and block your exchange so
you can think of your in your ledger of
transaction keeping when your
transaction your first formed on the
network Bakula out there in the 30 sort
of loose transactions that need to be
grouped together into blocks in a
network anyone who takes on the role of
a minor their job is to grab some of
these transactions down from B ether put
them into a block of a drawer to look
here and a block has several things in
it has a set of transactions agent
jumping to be basically - you can show
forth it also has the hash value of any
preview so
that we in the network going back that
Merkle tree structure additionally it
has something known as your non-spell
use which is just a random guess value
to impact the signature hash of the
clock hue hash the combination of the
record of transactions the hash value of
the previous block and this non-spell
you to generate a hash code certain
uniquely labels this block now the
region behind the nonce value is to hold
a hash puzzle this final hash code that
labels this block will happen here you
know it had to start with four heroes so
what a miner does gritty transactions
together and he put in random guesses
for that non-spell you until this hash
value that labels this block satisfies
the criteria of whatever the hash module
is where is this person come from do so
sure it's part of the mathematics of the
the proxy Network and it's a way of
certifying that agri a block is
legitimate and that it's agreed upon and
it's a way of managing the distributed
nature of the network because anyone can
take any collection of transactions very
light that are sort of out in the open
that not yet formed into a block and try
and create a block and there's this sort
of mathematical race of a sort of
compute power to solve this puzzle and
the first person who shows you it or the
first group of people that solve it
they're the ones that generate a block
that goes onto the chain so it your way
of managing the fact that everybody is
free to try and create blocks to add to
the chain so what happens then when okay
two people both happen to show a block
at the same moment at precisely the same
moment now he is rare but they happen
and in those instances you can get Forks
can block chains the people
the network that he one block added
dolphin and and try and build blocks on
top of that block whereas the people
that key a different block beeping added
golf and time continued the change in
another direction yeah how's that is
yells across the network how is it that
everyone has this single agreed-upon
ledger what happens is that the longer
essentially a sort of democracy
throughout the network but the longest
chain is the one that everyone agrees
they should take and the mathematic is
such but you're unlikely to sustain
Forks for a long period of time as you
know people are looking all the time to
update their current ledger to the
longest chain you're supposed to keep it
simple we have five people in our
network and we have a fourth changed we
have two images we have two competing
change it only takes three of those both
of five to have seen the you know the
longer of the two change for the best
bit contention submissively Bishop by
majority vote here were we're going to
reject any chain that shorter than the
longest chain the majority of the people
on the network I've seen what happens to
any transactions that happens with the
shortage only mutton you know in the
shorter chains that's where you're kind
of your transactions you're in that
group you're out of luck they go in to
the extent that they go back into the
ether they're not yet codified or or
incorporated into the blockchain and so
not process not not legitimate all of
this means is actually a slower system
at the moment not as well this will it
take happening very quickly at the
moment blocks are in again I use Bitcoin
cos you tweak the first system and you
know one of the most widely adopted in
the Bitcoin system lock your created
that the mathematical complexity of that
hash puzzle is on a sliding scale to
reflect the compute power of the network
at any given point
that blots will be created on average
every 10 minutes the further back in the
chain a particular blockage the less
likely it is for that came to be to the
found to be a a shorter fork and
discarded so that the current waiting
period is changing before counting that
the money in your wallet
let's ticks plot to be created and at
the moment that is back an hour so it's
not instantaneous but it's not too long
to wait and a bad point makes a very
slim chance that your transactions going
to go back into the ether and then you
know to be incorporated in a block later
on if you are in the unfortunate
circumstance where you were passed that
shorter fork of the blockchain and your
transaction hadn't been accepted and
it's been turned back into ether yes
you're just waiting for another miner to
come along grab that series of
transactions and try and build another
block you may need to leave this all
these and start filming about the fact
that there is going to be a pointer
which loan you Bitcoin go maybe that's
correct yes if some it's like me that
this mining will stop at a clue no but
how you will be complicated with more
change so at the moment bitcoins are
sort of being introduced to show you
through the mining process in that
you're being financially rewarded in
Bitcoin I think at this point in time
the creation of a block it merits hits
coins in the wallet of the miner or as
is commonly the case now with people
grouping compute power together the
group of people that are made after sort
of mining pool and at the point where
all of all bitcoins have been introduced
you'll no longer gain financially from
mining in that regard how you will then
gain be through transaction fees
and he's where people can give up
certain amount of their crank action
okay I want to send you he'll get a
Bitcoin I've got five in my County ahead
for rather than camping for back to me
maybe I can three and a half back to me
and I can give the other half to the
miner and during that way you'll be
financially compensated for the work of
of mining so it's a bit like a currency
exchange or PayPal little taste their
feeder toast rose is this this like this
distribution if these miners are
effectively actually like the agency
country well it to the extent where you
know that there will be the prank action
page which at the moment you know should
have not taking a big part of the
network because people are still getting
money just from doing the computation
work of curing hash modules but as a
system evolved and relies more upon
transaction fees then yes they would
have more of a role to play within the
network but they're still likely to be
far below your standard transaction fees
for exchanging you know Dalek pounds
from its original conception they only
ever intended and designed to be 21
million bitcoins in existence and you
can clearly like to radioactive
half-life controlling the release of
those we're going and how that's
reflected is the level of reward for
mining so every and kitty every 21,000
bitcoins in the book collection area
that have produced the rewards for
mining and creating a block its haft and
show you're introducing half the amount
of Bitcoin to kill in network if you
were previously in Toronto forth until
eventually or 21 million bitcoins have
been introduced to the network
same process in Reverse using the same
key and then they get hello
back out the other end and that's nice
and simple it works and it was once sort
of the only way that people did sing but
it has a problem which is you both need
to know